all right we'll open uh the work session
again on House Bill 5 506 I know that
the
oh the fire representative from Windham
would like to speak I was just
a scheduling conflict
I think we all know you but for the
record if you could state your name
please and thank you Mr chair Daniel
Popovich Miller representative from
Wyndham and as it was mentioned I do
have a scheduled conflict I much
appreciate the committee's willingness
to give me my one minute at the
beginning so I can go back to finance
too
foreign
just wanted to say that in regards to
this bill my concern for it was that it
was an opportunity for everybody
involved to be able to speak up and for
the community to get involved and help
determine what the right solution is
going forward together with the
Department of Transportation and you
know everybody affected by it and I just
wanted to State for the record that
because
of the
major benefits that in my opinion a
tunnel would have over the proposed
currently proposed solution I do support
the you know tunnel option
that's again my personal position I just
speak for myself but I wanted to make
that clear my concern is that it's a
value proposition sometimes saving a few
dollars while seriously impacting the
usability of the project is not the best
choice and in my opinion the tunnel will
be the best value in terms of the
benefits that we'll get versus the
reasonably small additional uh funding
required
thank you
are there any questions
seeing none thank you thank you
really appreciate you coming in
I know the prime sponsor would like to
add a few words before we go much
further sure if you could just state
your name again for the record sure
Representative Steve Pearson
p-e-a-r-s-o-n Rockingham District 13.
which encompasses the town of Derry
I just wanted to highlight some bullet
points just to kind of wrap this all up
here
um real quick so
the the the tunnel
was in the original design of this
project the tunnel was in the plan that
the feds approved in 2020. all bidders
under the bid Bill process bid the
tunnel
the final feis and record of decision
for 4A which includes the tunnel was
signed off by the dairy Town manager and
the dot in February of 20.
the tunnel design the tunnel design was
submitted to the dot by the firmofus and
O'Neill
the president of the dairy rail trail
was issued a gag order by a bidder on
this project the board of directors
never saw this proposal nor did it
approve anything
despite being Consulting parties to the
project the rail trail groups were shut
out of this process
a bidder's attempt to gain an unfair
advantage
submitted an alternative plan to the dot
and the dot ran with it
internal documents from the dot
questioned this move both from a safety
and environmental standpoint
the flood plain has been reduced from
100 years to 50.
retired dot Engineers refer to this plan
as problematic and one referred to it as
stupid
the May 7th
2021 email
the main contact for dairy Mike Fowler
director of Public Works emailed project
manager Wendy Johnson the town stance
has evolved to support the position to
build a rail trail specific Culvert on
the straight through alignment
this is from the director of Public
Works of the town of Derry
dated May 7 2021.
in June 8th of that same year a month
later
the response back was after much
consideration and deliberation it is
difficult with heavy heart that we say
we are going to proceed with the
combination of the two structures we
truly value and appreciate the town's
input and although this is not the
town's preference this is a email from
Wendy Johnson to the public works
director of the town of Derry although
this is not the town's preference we
hope that the town will be able to
support this difficult decision this is
June 8th of 21 that is an important date
a year later May 7th the Boston EPA
office expresses concerns about flooding
and management of the wetlands with this
alternative
and finally in September of 22 just a
mere
five months ago
the public finally hears and a public
hearing occurs with the dot telling
residents that their concerns will be
taken into consideration
remember that in June of the prior year
the dot told the town it is building the
alternative this proves that that public
hearing was a sham
not a single person in any public
hearing advocated for the spaghetti
Trail
the town of Derry did not ask
for the tunnel plan to be altered
and the May 7 2021 email from derry's
Public Works director specifically asked
the dot not to do it
no rail trail or outdoor recreation
group asked for this alternative
so we get to the point of the dot
setting sending a threatening letter to
the council to manipulate a vote
that they were considering taking
so the council instead votes to not
spend any additional money as they have
a contract with the state
that was the vote the town did not vote
for the alternative plan
that did not occur
and many Council has expressed their
opinion to keep the tunnel in the design
that is a summation of what amounts to
five inches of
submitted documentation emails
supporting pieces
to cover the gist of this particular
situation
I think we're going on our seven or
eight of in this matter which is a
little on the unprecedented side
are there questions for represent
Pearson yes Mr Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
question so this document says uh
greatly enhance the millions of dollars
currently coming in from Windham Dairy
and Londonderry can you show me this
provides an excellent Roi yeah sorry
that was a show what you were reading
sorry did you oh sorry are you did you
produce this document I did not this was
produced by the granite uh Granite State
rail folks apologies sorry uh but if
maybe if you can still answer the
question sure can you quantify the
excellent Roi or the millions that are
brought in
well they've done
um
I can tell you this I can tell you that
there have been studies that have looked
at that by out outside folks
um I have two businesses in my own town
that exists solely because of the
success of the rail trail that would not
be there otherwise
we've seen six
um the re-establishment of a prior
closed business in at Windham Junction
and the
the ancillary economic benefit of of
these of this particular piece of rail
bed had been studied by I think a group
out of unh and that's where they get
that from and they're better to clarify
its origin than I am
it's this
oh from okay
it's
all right
thank you and where and we're you know
we're still we don't even have a
completed
the the trail is is not even yet
completed and we're seeing these huge
numbers so the benefit
um will only increase from there when we
have the ability to
to pass all the way through from Salem
up to Manchester and and uh and vice
versa back to Salem certainly
thank you thank you for that sorry I
thought since it was passed out during
your Testament I thought but thank you
no problem
for other questions representative
Sweeney or no
seeing none I just had I want to thank
you for the work I think you probably
should be on the finance committee
because you're so thorough but I I might
have been asked to be on the finance
committee by the chairman of finance and
he was not granted his request
all right so you know further questions
sure thank you awesome thank you guys
too for all of you for for your
extraordinary efforts in this
so just a quick where are we
representative Weiler and I had a
meeting on Friday with the speaker and
others
to talk about this has gained quite a
bit of attention
and one of the things that came up is
perhaps that we would put it in the
budget the item has been discussed
thoroughly it's a budget year but I
don't want to take away from what folks
may have out there to say further but I
just want to let you know where we might
be going with it
um
and that being said uh Ari I can't
remember your last name but I know you
approached us it won't wish to speak
and again if you could state your name
and for the record please
there we go
yes thanks Mr chairman uh I'm our
Republic I'm with the law firm of
Gallagher Callahan and gartrell and I I
hope to take a couple of quick minutes
to give you a little bit of a different
perspective than you may have heard so
far in seven hours of discussion
you
represents yes
I'm getting there right now for the past
10 years I've been legal counsel for
Pillsbury Realty development Pillsbury
is the owner and the master developer of
the Woodmont Commons project that you've
heard about through these hearings
Pillsbury I'm sorry Woodmont Commons is
a 600 acre master planned mixed-use
development entirely in Londonderry
straddles Dairy it's located in
Londonderry
to this point we've developed a
four-story apartment building
a single-family subdivision a brewery a
brew pub a gym a medical office building
and an entire senior housing community
there's a lot more in the planning and
development stages that's truly the
beginning
there's 200 Acres of this project that's
on the east side of I-93 between the
highway and the town of Derry line we
call it the east side and for decades
it's waited for exit 4A
uh the Taylor caswell's group over at
New Hampshire Bea Town officials of both
towns Town staff countless real estate
brokers they've brought us interested
parties who are interested in developing
on woodmont's East side this 200 acres
in the 4A area every opportunity
involves serious investment in New
Hampshire serious job creation not
dozens of jobs but hundreds of jobs and
every one of these conversations ends
the same way very exciting let us know
when the road's done
um phase a of the exit project is
finally underway after decades you've
heard about it Decades of studies
permitting design changes budget gaps uh
rfps High bids new studies staff changes
retirements I can give you more reasons
we're closer than we ever have before
but phase a is just part of the story it
is currently a road that excuse me does
not connect to other public roads it
needs phase B where this tunnel
path debate is occurring and then phase
C to connect to the Derry Public Road
Network
we are at we Pillsbury actively
negotiating with multiple parties but as
this committee has heard from many
people over the years time kills these
deals and new and additional delays even
small delays after so many delays will
kill these deals too and it's these big
deals have real consequences to the
state to job creation housing creation
all the things that I know are
priorities in the state house and for
this committee
it's been mentioned by a few speakers
that Pillsbury owns a portion of the
rail trail Corridor that is true
Pillsbury owns about a five acre chunk
of the trail north of shields Brook
where this debate is occurring north of
this tunnel concept area pillsbury's
chunk is in Londonderry and it's
privately owned the chunk is necessary
to connect the trail
a trail with The Gap isn't a trail
that's two trails with a hole in the
middle
Pillsbury has repeatedly pledged to open
its connecting piece to public use
it's uh we're presently talking with the
Londonderry Trail group I understand to
be different group than the Derry Trail
group about a license to the town of
Londonderry for the public to use
maintain this portion of trail on
private land
the trail is a wonderful Community
amenity it's going to be enjoyed by many
enhance the Woodmont project as much as
anything and we're in support
we are not in support of delay and we
are not in support of changing designs
whether they were the original design or
the next design or the one after that
were not in favor of anything that
causes more delays because we can tell
you that dot is waiting their pencil is
down they need some direction now that
all of this has been fluffed up and
those delays have real consequences and
I can share with you every story if you
ever wanted to hear them the the
conversation ends the same let us know
when the road is done
Pillsbury has no dog in the design fight
we understand both sides we appreciate
that safety is a priority for everyone
who has a dog in that fight those are
the best of reasons we know that dot
prioritizes safety and we know that you
know that we know dot has the state's
Authority and best interests in mind
when they build roads when they design
roads and when they go through the
10-year process and public stakeholder
process to propose roads put them out to
bid construct them and maintain them we
know simply put that when the state
wants to build the road it calls Dot
so it's our view
that dot should be allowed to finish
what they've started and that frankly a
bill that started with criminal
implications and I recognize that's been
amended out but a bill that started with
criminal implications gave this whole
debate a very odd and different flavor
and if it was really just about how do
you design a passage that's safe for The
Pedestrian and bicyclist Community I
think this committee might have just
said we don't even know why we have this
bill and we're not we're not in the
business of Designing roads tunnels or
Bridges
I don't know how dot could do its job
with criminal implications hanging over
their head I don't know how I could do
my job with criminal implications
hanging over my head we supp we we
support itl on this bill not because we
have a dog in the fight but we have a
dog in the fight of delay and D.O.T
needs a clear signal from this state
house to pick up their pencil finished
their work finish the road and put those
opportunities on the ground so that
these development Partners can come in
invest in New Hampshire provide the jobs
that I know will be uses that are
popular in the communities and anything
less than that will cause more delay in
the consequences of delay are real I
appreciate you taking the time I know
you've had more than enough thank you
are there any questions
representable
for coming I think it's good to hear
from the business community in a greater
extent about the about
this issue I don't know if you can
answer this question but do you have a
sense of the attitude of the broader
business Community with respect to the
delay that this bill's passage might
cause I I've heard it in many many
places over the years that the delays
associated with the 4A project are
just depressing upsetting causing real
concern causing other businesses to hold
back on investment this
exit project and I'm not speaking
specifically to the rail trail or
bicycling design and I'm not an expert
on any of those subjects but I can tell
you that if you have a property you
don't have a road to you can't develop
it and this exit project has been lauded
for decades as opening up a tremendous
opportunity in that region of the state
and it's again on the ropes
further question representative both
seeing none thanks for appreciate the
time thank you
so I have been in communication with the
D.O.T commissioner
he regrets that there's been any
perception that his correspondence with
anyone in the group was uh appeared as
threatening and he reiterated he wants
to see this work forward and that um
he puts his hand out to work with the
community to make sure everything is
done and wanted me to remind
everybody here that whatever happens it
will be the complete responsibility of
the town of dairy to maintain what is
ever left after the D.O.T is finished
with the project so one of get the
commissioner's thoughts out there
yes the good representative from Epping
right Epsom I'm getting there trying to
think I'd like to ask uh Ms Johnson some
questions if you may
yeah absolutely yeah
and again if you could please State your
names for the record please
for the record my name is David rodrigue
and I'm the assistant commissioner for
the Department of Transportation
my name is Wendy Johnson I'm the I'm the
project manager for the exit 4A project
nhdot thank you so um representative
Pearson just said that the this project
could somehow affect Wetlands is that
true
there are wetlands impacted for the for
the entire project and whether we go
with the bridge option with the tunnel
underneath the roadway or if we go with
a Shields broke option there are both
have Wetland impacts
is some somehow worse than the other or
different or I mean what is it there's
there's slightly more Wetlands impacts
with the one on Shields Brook as we
currently have it designed we're still
working on refining the total design but
it's on the order of about 60 extra
square feet
would there be any Wetlands impact of
just a grade level crossing
so so not doing a tunnel or an underpass
yes there would be no additional impacts
with that option no okay yes so um I'm
familiar with Keith Coda who was had
your job before you did and
um he explained to me some of the
history is related to the difference
between the design build process and the
design bid build process can you explain
what happened here in that regard yeah
perfect so when we start to do a design
we get to a point where we're getting
ready to go to a hearing that's about
our 25 design stage and at that point we
make a decision of whether we're going
to design it in-house get everything all
together put together a bid package
solicit it for bids and then have a
contractor build it so that's a regular
that's the standard process the standard
procurement you would usually see the
second way that we can do it or there's
actually three ways but the second way
that we look at most often is a design
is a design build and in that case we
get to that same 25 design we go to the
we go to the public hearing and then we
step back and we send the whole thing
out to be advertised so they come up
with uh the design they do all their
right-of-way Acquisitions they do all of
that stuff which would usually happen in
our design window so the contractor and
the cons and a consultant team up
together and they do the whole project
right from that point and so when they
do
um these design build projects they're
given you know there's they weight each
portion of how the the design is done by
who can who can do at least expensively
who can do it faster and so they're
incentivized to come up with ways that
could improve the design and those are
called alternative technical Concepts
these are those atcs that everybody's
been talking about and the trail was one
one of those atcs
so why was this design build process
used in this case when what I understand
from him is design bid build is more
common
so design bid build is more common and
the reason that we tried to go with the
other way is a lot of times you can save
a lot of time going in that route
because you're designing and building at
the same exact time so right now we have
to go through a couple years to design
it and then we put it out to build and
everything is all set when you combine
the designing and the building all at
the same time you can be working on your
right-of-way negotiations while you're
relocating some utilities while you're
doing all that stuff and it doesn't have
to wait until you have a Contractor on
board so sometimes you can get it you
can get the design on the road more
quickly
all right
yeah so let's talk about grade level
crossing because to me
I've how many streets do you see that
have tunnels right next to none
um is there something special I went out
to this location there's nothing there
right it's a bit it's in the middle of
nowhere it leads to you know a trail in
the middle of the woods Etc
is there something special about this
location that that somehow zillions of
people are going to be Crossing and
going through it
by comparison to if I were to walk to
Holiday Inn here I crossed a six five or
six Lane Road very busy
on the street right with a walk light
why why does this location somehow weird
that it needs something else compared to
its crosswalk
so that's a great question so when they
were doing all that initial design that
beginning part before the hearing when
Keith was working on the project they go
out to the public and they gain
different pieces of information and they
go to the natural resource agencies and
they get counts and they try to project
what's going to happen
during that phase of the design they
decided that we would offer a grade
separated alternative to the at grade at
to the ad grade crossing we never the
documents don't say it has to be a
tunnel it has to be this has to be that
it just says we agreed to a agreed
separated location simply because it
made sense from uh the amount of vehicle
uh pedestrians and and bicyclists
yes yeah I mean so do you think the
number of pedestrians in that location
is somehow different than the number of
pedestrians greater than the number of
pedestrians on Main Street in Concord or
something like that you see what I mean
I I do hear what you're saying I don't
know the numbers in Concord but I can
say that the you know if you anecdotally
speaking just to the south of here
there's plenty of other Crossings of
similar type roads on the same exact
quarter that do not have a grade
separated Crossing you're correct
all right thank you
representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman
I'm searching my memory and my
the relevant topics on rail trails
most of these were when the railroad
could buy property pretty cheap because
it was mainly farmlands that was back
before 1900
and they went directly from one
populated area to another with very
little in between so the property was
reasonably cheap
way before any of us were on this
committee the state realized the value
of these straight-line
things that would be very difficult to
obtain later on as the property values
went up so they required whenever the
the railroad abandoned one it went to
the state
now one of the things I discovered many
years ago we were looking at a proposed
rail trail crossover of a road maybe
maybe it was a stream but the point was
that the bridge over it was going to
cost twice as much as as we thought it
should have and we said why is it
so strong and so on the answer was this
well
the phone company or the cable company
runs cables down the railroads right
away because they're so direct they
don't have to hassle with 100 landowners
they just
get a lease from the from the railroad
and now they've got a straight line
going from one place to another
and I said so
do we get paid by the cable company for
this oh no
who gets paid for it the railroad well
the railroad doesn't own it anymore
well they offered us when they sold us
the right-of-way
to buy that lease and we said no we
can't afford it
so we still have to maintain the cables
going down the railroad right away
and they get paid for them the railroad
it also occurs to me that these straight
line things are so valuable it's such a
valuable asset to the state and now
recently we're hearing about today water
and we keep hearing in Rockingham County
they want more water some of it they
want to get from Manchester and
Pentucket now it would seem the ideal
way to run a water line would also be as
straight as possible and that might be a
possibility for a railroad right away
but it would want to be straight
as possible and as direct as possible
and I think it's something that maybe we
should look at when we're considering
spreading water lines around the state
we should look at railroad right-of-ways
which we own it would make it so much
easier especially if the state is making
a major contribution so my question is
that I finally getting to is does DOT
have a cable right away down this
railroad right away that
you know of do you know that there's any
telephone cables or whatever cables
going down this right away that the
state is receiving money for
so thank you for your question a little
further explanation about what you
described for this particular portion of
what was referred to as I believe the
Manchester Lawrence Branch but please
yes the Manchester Lawrence branch of
the rail right-of-way
that right of way was largely dissolved
in this area in 1985 and in 1986.
directly south of this exit 4A project
the town of Derry purchased that
right-of-way from the Manchester
Lawrence and I testified to this last
time if you look at where the the rail
trail now runs through the town of Derry
it's concurrent with some side streets
it's directly adjacent to buildings and
it's through some parking lots so I
think when they look at where they run
the water line they put it down Route 28
because that was a much more direct
route than it would be to go through the
community
furthermore the the northern section of
this rail trail that's directly
underneath our project area was was
purchased by a private entity and the
state no longer has an interest in it
with respect to right-of-ways there is a
fiber optic line that runs underneath
that that right-of-way and is and is
accommodated but I'll tell you when we
get into talking about the amendment the
way the amendment is is written we have
some very serious concerns because right
now North High Street is designed to be
constructed directly over this entire
railroad right-of-way Corridor and if we
have to follow the terms of this
amendment we'll have to relocate the
North High Street design which we're
talking about a very major design change
at this point in the project
I know there are other complications and
and I can't believe the state didn't
move right in when this was abandoned in
85 like they had in all the others why
did I screw that up I'm sorry I wasn't
here in 1985 I can't tell yeah somebody
that's long dead probably on that
decision but it's one of the greatest
reasons why we always grab a
a railroad right away because it's so
difficult to get it right away in
today's market I can tell you in 19 I
and I have the dates here for for the
right away so if you'll if you'll bear
with me in 1985 when the portion was
sold to the town of Derry the state did
maintain that that that be held as a
transportation right-of-way for the
future so we have it on that piece
somehow we missed it on on this piece
between that Northern Terminus and the
town of London there and now it gives us
problems so there is in fact a fiber
optic cable running along this right
away there is in fact the fiber optic
cable running in that right away how are
you going to accommodate it with this
design
our Wendy provide the details
so the fiber optic line is if you look
at the plan um High Street is is here
the fiber optic line is slightly to the
right of that or to the east of that we
don't impact it with our current design
and it's also it's a little bit deeper
than you know like a water line might be
it's probably you know eight feet eight
feet deep so the design is Worth showing
it except for a couple of driveways
doesn't doesn't go near that fiber optic
line what if the tunnel went in how
would that affect it
so that would be a different scenario
although I did take a quick look at it
you know just the back of the enveloping
and I think it would we would be able to
to put something in with minimal impacts
to it but I think we would we would have
some sort of impact to it
thank you I just thought that question
up the other night thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative while I did
notice the Do Not dig a t markers all
through there so
I guess I could confirm that there is
something there
further questions representative Griffin
representative Peterson
when he testified earlier he said that
the bid package went out her proposal
whenever we call it then included the
tunnel
all right and I'm interested in
how that
then created the
the
design and build concept
in other words the original build bid
package went out asking for bids
but it wasn't a design bill
proposal was it
sure yeah the original package that went
out was the design the design bid design
build so nothing was actually designed
it was like a concept on the plan sheet
so when they were looking at what they
could do to to you know to to make their
design better and and make some
improvements on it that's when they came
up with the alternative to remove the
tunnel save the time of constructing the
second the second structure reduced
maintenance move the structure to the
right so what happens is they do that
ATC which I was talking about that
alternative technical concept as we
didn't go with the design build process
what we end up doing is we end up having
to pay the the people uh stipend and
when we when we pay for the stipend we
get everything back that they had done
so we pay the stipend so now we own that
design and so the next part that we had
done once we had transitioned that
happened in the fall of was you know so
the fall had happened then we were going
to put the project back out for
um for solicitation to get the
consultant on board to design it and
then build it so when we did that
process we took a look at everything
that they had done and we had at that
point we had contacted
um the town and the town had us contact
UM the trail groups and at that point
they had said well this is this is
something we weren't supposed to talk
about and I said no we own these now
we're allowed to talk about them and
they had no objection at that point I
didn't say they agreed they had no
objection
um and so we brought that back at that
point
um to the town we said they have no
objections we went back and forth and
that's when we went forward and I know
that he had read about the you know we
went back and forth and back and forth
and the there's one piece missing in
there that after we talked to the town
and we had um you know we told the town
that we were going to go in this
direction because we were trying to make
decisions quickly and move forward we
did end up having some conversations
with the town and then everybody had had
some some thoughts we did talk about it
sit down and talked about it and at that
point they said yeah you know if we're
going to have to maintain these
structures and we're going to be
responsible the ultimate maintenance and
all of this in the future that we we
don't want to take on that second
structure if it's going to be our
structure we don't want to take on that
structure so that's how we got from the
Department saying you know we hope you
can we hope you can you can you can work
with us on this to them actually coming
around to say yeah now that we think
about it we really we really don't want
it and then that's how we ended up at
that location did I did I answer what
you were looking for
this is more common than a question but
if we had known I think if we had known
the bidding process if it had been made
clear To Us by the Department of
Transportation I know what you two
people were not at the original meeting
but nobody made clear that that was the
type bid that was sent out that it was a
design Bill and that you're looking for
that type proposal and I think it would
have saved us hours
of effort had we known that
if I may Mr yes I was just going to say
there's been plenty of discussion on the
matter but yes go ahead sir
thank you I just wanted to that point
particular we were here at the first
hearing and we were ready to to testify
to that and I just to to clarify we keep
referring to this or not we this has
often been referred to as a rail trail
project or a tunnel project what the
Department of Transportation is building
is the exit 4A project that constructs a
new exit on the interstate and connects
that exit and Recon builds a new road
and reconstructs Roads existing roads
through Dairy to connect I-93 to Route
102. this is a design element in the
project so it is very important to us
all design elements are very important
to us but in the big scheme of things
this is a very small piece of the
project the design build projects as
Wendy had testified they were progressed
to 25 percent it is not uncommon for
these Design Elements to change during
the progression of of the project and
very much as representative Maguire has
has talked about the crossing at the
signalized intersection using the walk
don't walk button the bottom line with
all of these options cross at the signal
cross at the tunnel or cross under
Shields Brook is there a pros and cons
advantages and disadvantages to each
option and the department works works
hard to weigh those and come out with
the best option what we believe the best
option with the communities that we're
building that and considering Public
public input do we always get it right
for all the people it's impossible to
when the op options range from pushing
the button and everybody having to wait
for a walk cycle to a path under Shields
brook or to a path under a tunnel
I accept all that you said I understand
that what I'm trying to point out is
that had we known more early on it would
have been very helpful when as know more
about the bidding process early on and
that it was in fact a design build
thank you
second your comments there because we've
spent an awful lot of time on this and
if perhaps we'd gotten all the
information in the front end versus
10 hours later would have been helpful
but it is what it is and we'll try to
deal what we have
I guess a follow-up to representative
McGuire's question that's the problem
when you ask questions you can get other
questions but he referenced you know
someone Crossing Main Street which I
think has got a posted speed limit of
perhaps 20 25 miles an hour the speed on
this I'm sure is going to be what 40 or
more is it what is your speed design
because it's going to be a a connector
road to the interstate
it is going to be a connector Road and I
I apologize I should know that off the
top of my head but I believe it is going
to be around the 40 mile an hour range
but I can get back to the committee with
that thanks
we'll go with representative Hewitt and
then representative Sweeney
going over all of this stuff I noticed
that
there is a environmental impact
statement accompanying this project
appears to have been done around 2015 or
something like that I've I've got it
right here somewhere
um
the question I have is at the time the
environmental impact statement was made
didn't was there that had to be I guess
was there actually a plan
in some something that that
caused the environmental impact
statement to be taken up by the by the
federal government
um
would
the the plan that's uh that's included
in this legislation
require any changes to the environmental
impact statement or don't you know
so that's that's a very good question so
the environmental impact statement is
always done prior to the time that we go
to the public hearing so that's going to
be about that 25 design time so we don't
know exactly what we're going to be
doing because designs get refined as you
keep designing the project all along
and so what happens is prior to
advertising the project we would go and
we would formalize what our official and
final impacts would be and that's when
we would apply back to the you know
nhdes Army Corps of Engineers to get the
actual permits so in that particular
case we we are in still in line with
everything that was impacted previously
so if we change any major element like
in this particular case if we went to
the tunnel to the crossing under Shields
Brook although it still has the same
utility we would have to apply for
something called a niba reevaluation so
it goes back and takes a look at that
what did we change and what does it
impact you know are there a lot more
Wetlands impacts or whatnot and we're in
the process of doing that for this for
this project
okay and in connection with all this
back several years ago uh the town and
the department of trans station and also
the town was what's the other Town
Londonderry and Londonderry and dairy
and into a contract uh with the
Department of Transportation uh
got governing a lot of this stuff
um
and suggesting what was going to be done
and bringing up the issue that the towns
of the Londonderry and dairy were not
going to incur any further expense
beyond the five million dollars that was
originally included in the contract and
this contract uh was at the time it was
signed by both parties and also approved
by the Attorney General uh is that is
that would that would anything that's
going on now impact that
thank you for your question so I believe
we did talk about this last week as as
well the the municipal agreement stated
what both communities Darien Londonderry
would do and what the Department of
Transportation would do to to finish
this project
the the department is very very familiar
with the municipal agreement that that
one explains the the terms and there are
terms within the municipal agreement to
revisit cost should cost an increase and
if you'd like me to to take a minute I
can read those sections from the
municipal agreement for you
you can yeah it would be good to have
that in the record I have them here so
good
and that agreement makes it clear that
anything in excess I believe of the five
million dollars from either Community
will be borne by the state or others is
that correct
I I don't know that I I do think if the
state provided it and the department and
it came through the department I don't
see where that would be an issue if
that's what you're asking
representative Sweeney you had a
question thank you very much chairman I
thank you for being here again I'll try
to be as quick as possible so you had
mentioned I think in your answer to
representative Griffin that this is the
exit 4A plan this isn't you know the
whole project is not for the rail trail
what I'm trying to to
grapple in my mind
is why is it not Road first Trail second
on the construction schedule why is it
so intermixed where if we were to go
with the tunnel plan or one other plan
it would cause such a drastic delay in
the development of getting exit 4A open
if can we not
get that access road complete without
tackling the rail trail concurrently or
what yeah that's basically it because if
if we skipped over the whole tunnel and
in in the in the um the combination of
the structure we're still going to build
shieldsbruck but if we had to come back
and put a tunnel in underneath we'd have
to rip up everything that we had already
just built so it wouldn't you would be
losing money and you'd be losing time
because then you have to design that
again and fix figure out how you're
going to match it all in and then come
back and do it so this design and then
the other component would be is if we we
put a pause on the tunnel and then we
come back and do the tunnel later then
all of those right-of-way properties
that we would have purchased we have to
go back into it again and so we need to
know we need to know which way we're
going to be designing the whole thing
because that's how we approach the whole
design before we can in the same thing
for like Wetlands permitting and all
that sort of thing we want to apply once
because the amount of wetlands impacts
we have depends on what our mitigation
is and if we don't need extra mitigation
we don't want to be paying those upfront
costs either if that makes sense
thank you for your question
I'm just going to be buying the division
that uh chair Weiler and
the good representative from Epson
foreign
need to get out of here shortly for
another hearing representative evil
thank you for being here this is really
difficult because there's there's so
many facts to come in that we're trying
to learn and absorb and retain as we try
to make a judgment so I frequently will
just track back to Derry and that final
decision that we had from the Town
Council where they said that they were
just going to leave things the way they
were because they didn't want to incur
additional cost and they didn't want to
incur additional DeLay So I've been if
if the if we put this in the budget that
takes care of the cost part but it
doesn't really take care of the delay
part
so
I I just want to make sure as the
committee makes a decision that we fully
understand the ramifications of a
decision to retain and put it in the
budget or pass it
um you know
I think that we have to remember to
build in whatever we do
a bill has to get through the
legislative process so that that's
several months I don't know what you
guys do in the meantime
and then once a decision is made so
let's say it goes in the budget and the
budget passes
um you know what gets picked up there
so that's my question I just the the
other part of this is though that we
can't forget that monies have already
been expended in pursuing the existing
plan
which are based largely lost
um yeah so I I'm just trying I just want
to make sure we focus as much on the
delay issue we've heard from a
representative of the business Community
um and try not to think quite as much
about the financial part
yep
thank you thank you for your question so
um you you described the the process
exactly and the way I I'll address this
is to talk about risk when we look at in
an entire project we talk about risk
there's Financial Risk and there's risk
due to time as well and of course as
you've heard a lot of testimony about
different designs posts different risks
to Transportation users at the end of
the day
but but what a bill like this does at
this point in our design we are working
full speed to deliver this this project
as quickly as we can our commissioner at
most every executive council meeting is
asked by the counselors house foray
going wins 4A going to to be done we we
have been pushing towards design and and
delivery of this this project
to an extent this whole discussion has
interfered with with our ability to
continue the design with confidence
right because we don't know what this
final element is is going to be we are
moving forward on the things that we can
but as we talked about last time when
will this bill
be passed when will it be signed by the
governor I went through a list a partial
lists of 16 steps that we would have to
go through which includes in an
amendment that would then need to be
approved by the governor and Council
another legislative body for us to to
move forward and implement this change
so the delays are very very real we
expect if we continue on our current
course we will see construction of this
project out there next year 2024 if we
change course and go to the the tunnel
design traffic will be or construction
stock will be delayed till 2025.
with we a representative why you have a
question represent Kimbrell's
yes Mr chair I could just be permitted
for just a very quick question
representative McGuire and
representative Weiler have to run but
yeah very quickly yeah yeah yes he does
just just a quick theoretical question
if we were to kill this bill and not
provide the funding and the town of
Derry were to write you a check to cover
all the costs to do the tunnel project
would you be compelled to build a tunnel
or would you still hold ground that um
that it's not worth it because of the
delays
so what the Town Council has been clear
on in a bowl is they want no delays the
the Town Council
ex
hold on please we need to really move
this along I I
recognize your passion but in all due
respect and I'm going through all these
records and I see this has been going on
since 1985 and we're still here we
shouldn't be here this shouldn't be
before our division to be quite candid
with you but
um
I've seen the correspondence from
several town councils that disagree with
your interpretation of their vote I
provided a copy of one of those letters
to the commissioner that and he
responded to that concern I think we
really need to move on and my personal
thought is that we should put this in
the budget it's a budget year and we'll
check with Mr Hoffman if that goes
forward to see how much we should add
with a 750 is adequate or more money but
that's my position representative Weiler
I moved to retain because as you say
we'll put this in the bill I'll put this
in the in the budget we'll have longer
discussions with DOT we can urge them to
move this up and their priorities and
obviously from what has been said even
if we pass this bill it's still going to
be a year before anything starts
if we retain it put it in the bill hit
further discussions with Dot and say
Here's what we're putting in the budget
here's what we want to happen and
that'll be over in in division two but
those of us that have sat in on this can
go over and and share the history with
them you and I with once we have
conversations with every day in division
two as well and tell them what we want
to happen and that way maybe we have a
little more pressure on the dot so I
moved to retain I think in the motion
the motion's been made and seconded by
representing cambrell's if the clerk is
ready if he could please call the roll
we have way too much paper and we
haven't even started with the budget yet
Maguire absent
uh Griffin
to retain the ball to retain
Sweeney yes
emerils yes
purple chess
do it no
evil
no
chair Leachman yes
I put myself on every division
and a bowl of six two three or two the
motion carries
bills retained thank you Mr Clerk and we
will be in touch as this moves forward
with the Department
thanks for your attendance
thank you
oh yeah
very first year
his wife